Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Three, Episode Two: pensions, getting people to work, equality, and taxes.
The welfare state depends on the economic development in society.
In the period 1957 to 73 there was strong economic growth.
So the 1960s were years of very high growth, with rising production and consumption and high employment.
The growth in the public sector also continued at a high pace through the 1970s, despite a long economic crisis.
It became more and more clear, however, that the economy had difficulty bearing the development in public expenditure.
So the brakes were put on in the 1980s, and since then growth in public expenditure has continued at a more limited pace, so that it has roughly followed the general growth in the economy.
One of the biggest long-term challenges for the welfare state in Denmark and other European countries is that there are fewer people to pay for the welfare that more people are to enjoy.
That is primarily because life expectancy is rising, but also because the birth rate has been low for many decades.
People therefore speak of the so-called dependency burden, forsørgerbyrde, or the demographic pressure, having risen.
From 1980 to 2026, the share of citizens in Denmark over 64 has grown from 14 percent to 21 percent of the total population.
An important part of the solution has therefore been to extend the working age.
That is, the age at which you are, as a main rule, in the labour market.
The Folketing decided in 2006 that the old-age pension age should be raised as Danes live longer.
The pension age was 65 up to and including 2018, but is gradually being raised: first to 67 in 2022, then to 68 from 2030, and 69 from 2035.
In addition, it was decided in 2011 to shorten the early retirement scheme, efterløn.
Efterløn was introduced in 1979 as a right for people over 60 to withdraw from the labour market before the pension age.
In recent years there has also been a slightly smaller movement in the other direction.
From 2022, people who at 61 have been a long time, 42 to 44 years, in the labour market have got the right to retire one to three years before the old-age pension age.
This is called early pension, tidlig pension.
Early pension is also called the "Arne pension", after the brewery worker Arne Juhl, who became the face of the Social Democrats' election campaign at the general election in 2019 to get the scheme introduced.
The early retirement age was gradually raised from 60 to 62 from 2014 to 2017, and then the period is gradually shortened to 3 years, so that from 2023 you can go on efterløn from the age of 64 to 67.
For most people the benefit also becomes smaller, because the benefit is reduced to a greater extent in relation to how much pension savings the recipient has.
There have also been attempts to get more people into work by shortening the so-called unemployment benefit period, the dagpengeperiode, that is the period in which you can receive support as unemployed from an unemployment insurance fund, an A-kasse.
In 1993 a limit of seven years was set for the unemployment benefit period, and it has been continuously reduced: in 1995 to five years, in 1998 to four years, and since 2010 it has been two years.
At the same time, greater demands are today made to take other work than what you are trained for.
Furthermore, income tax has been lowered for people in work, including with a so-called employment deduction, beskæftigelsesfradrag, that is an amount you do not have to pay tax on if you are in work or have a surplus in your business.
This increases the benefit of being in work, even in jobs with a low wage.
Finally, a number of initiatives have been carried out to get more people into work among the groups that have had difficulty finding work.
It has thus become harder for those who have a lasting and significantly reduced ability to work to get the disability-type early retirement pension, førtidspension.
Instead they have been given the opportunity to work in a so-called flex job, fleksjob, so that they earn a good part themselves and get a public benefit for the rest.
Employment for people with a non-Western immigrant background has also risen overall since 1995, though with large fluctuations in the period.
For example it fell for a number of years after the financial crisis in 2008, and then rose again from 2015 to 16.
But many in this group are still outside the labour market.
In 2024, 68 percent of immigrants with a non-Western background between 25 and 64 were in work, against 83 percent of people of Danish origin in the same age group.
High employment in Denmark contributes to a high level of prosperity, and to Denmark being able to finance an expanded public sector.
Now to equality and redistribution.
The Danish welfare society is characterised by considerable economic redistribution.
This redistribution takes place both through the tax system, because those who earn the most pay the most in tax, and because the welfare state's benefits are given to everyone, and not least to those who are not in work.
Inequality did fall significantly in the period 1945 to 80.
That was especially due to the rapid expansion of the welfare society, large wage increases and long periods of low unemployment.
Inequality has, however, become greater since the 1980s.
This is due, among other things, to the tax system redistributing less from high to low incomes than before, to wage differences having become bigger, and to the value of homes in Copenhagen having grown very quickly over the last 10 to 15 years, which has created bigger differences in wealth.
Denmark still has a relatively high degree of economic equality compared with other countries.
How is it all paid for?
The Danish welfare society is financed through taxes on, for example, income, and through, among other things, VAT, moms, and duties on goods and services.
Moms, VAT, is a duty on goods and services you buy, for example in the shops.
It is not a tax on your income.
Both the state and the municipalities have the right to levy income tax.
Only the state and the municipalities levy income tax: the regions cannot levy taxes.
In 1903, income tax was introduced as a permanent tax.
It was introduced with a markedly lower tax percentage than today.
Income tax means that almost all incomes are taxable, regardless of where they come from.
The Danish income tax is progressive.
That means the percentage you have to pay in tax rises for high incomes.
Thus people with high incomes pay not only a higher amount in tax than people with lower incomes, but also a bigger share of their wage.
Income taxes make up a large part of the taxes in Denmark.
They redistribute more than duties on consumption, for example VAT, because people with lower incomes typically spend a larger share of their wage, which they thereby pay VAT on, while people with a higher income typically save more.
Everyone has a so-called basic deduction, a bundfradrag, an amount on which you do not pay income tax, of the first 54,100 kroner in 2026 that you earn in a year.
On income above the deduction you pay 12 percent in tax to the state and about 25 percent to your municipality.
If you are a member of the national church, folkekirken, you also typically pay about 1 percent church tax.
Church tax is paid only by taxable members of the national church.
Not everyone pays it, and non-members pay no church tax.
In addition, the state collects tax on the highest incomes, so that you pay: a "middle tax", mellemskat, of 7.5 percent on income above 618,400 kroner a year.
A "top tax", topskat, of 15 percent on income above 750,000 kroner a year.
And a "top-top tax", toptopskat, of 20 percent on income above 2.5 million kroner a year.
Here is your recap for Episode Two.
Public expenditure growth was brought under control in the 1980s.
The share of citizens over 64 grew from 14 percent in 1980 to 21 percent in 2026.
The old-age pension age was 65 until 2018, 67 in 2022, 68 from 2030 and 69 from 2035; the decision was made in 2006.
Efterløn was introduced in 1979 for people over 60 and shortened from 2011.
Early pension, the Arne pension, started in 2022.
The unemployment benefit period was seven years in 1993, five in 1995, four in 1998, and two years since 2010.
In 2024, 68 percent of non-Western immigrants aged 25 to 64 were employed, against 83 percent of people of Danish origin.
Inequality fell from 1945 to 80 and has grown since the 1980s.
Income tax became permanent in 1903, and is progressive.
The 2026 basic deduction is 54,100 kroner; 12 percent goes to the state and about 25 percent to the municipality, plus about 1 percent church tax for members only.
Moms is a duty on goods you buy.
The regions cannot levy taxes.
Middle tax is 7.5 percent above 618,400 kroner, top tax 15 percent above 750,000, and top-top tax 20 percent above 2.5 million.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What has happened to the old-age pension age since 2018?
Option A: It has become higher.
Option B: It is unchanged.
Option C: It has become lower.
[DA] Hvad er der sket med folkepensionsalderen siden 2018?  A: Den er blevet højere  |  B: Den er uændret  |  C: Den er blevet lavere
The answer is A: It has become higher.
It appeared in the November 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Den er blevet højere
Question 2.
How has the unemployment benefit period for the unemployed developed since 1994?
Option A: It has become longer.
Option B: It is unchanged.
Option C: It has become shorter.
[DA] Hvordan har dagpengeperioden for arbejdsløse udviklet sig siden 1994?  A: Den er blevet længere  |  B: Den er uændret  |  C: Den er blevet kortere
The answer is C: It has become shorter.
It appeared in the November 2022 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Den er blevet kortere
Question 3.
What characterised the 1960s in Denmark, among other things?
Option A: Oil crisis and high unemployment.
Option B: High economic growth with a big increase in production and consumption.
[DA] Hvad karakteriserede blandt andet 1960’erne i Danmark?  A: Oliekrise og høj arbejdsløshed  |  B: Høj økonomisk vækst med stor stigning i produktion og forbrug
The answer is B: High economic growth with a big increase in production and consumption.
It appeared in the November 2021 and November 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Høj økonomisk vækst med stor stigning i produktion og forbrug
Question 4.
What is moms, VAT?
Option A: A duty on, among other things, goods you buy in the shops.
Option B: A tax you pay on your income.
Option C: A fee you pay for access to DR's TV and radio channels.
[DA] Hvad er moms?  A: En afgift på blandt andet varer man køber i butikkerne  |  B: En skat man betaler af sin indkomst  |  C: Et gebyr man betaler for at have adgang til DR's tv- og radiokanaler
The answer is A: A duty on, among other things, goods you buy in the shops.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: En afgift på blandt andet varer man køber i butikkerne
Question 5.
Do all taxable citizens pay church tax?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Betaler alle skattepligtige borgere kirkeskat?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the June 2022 and May 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 6.
Who must pay church tax?
Option A: All taxable citizens.
Option B: Taxable members of the national church, folkekirken.
[DA] Hvem skal betale kirkeskat?  A: Alle skattepligtige borgere  |  B: Skattepligtige medlemmer af folkekirken
The answer is B: Taxable members of the national church, folkekirken.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Skattepligtige medlemmer af folkekirken
Question 7.
Can the regions levy taxes?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Kan regionerne opkræve skatter?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the May 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 8.
Which authorities levy taxes?
Option A: The state and the regions.
Option B: The state and the municipalities.
Option C: The regions and the municipalities.
[DA] Hvilke myndigheder udskriver skatter?  A: Staten og regionerne  |  B: Staten og kommunerne  |  C: Regionerne og kommunerne
The answer is B: The state and the municipalities.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Staten og kommunerne
That's the end of this part.
Well done.